South Bend Indiana mayor Pete Buda
judge's decision to run for president
was a surprise when he first mentioned
it to his husband the Afghan war veteran
would be the first openly gay nominee of
a major presidential party if he wins
the nomination he would also be the
youngest person ever to become president
he will be 38 years old in November 2020
we spoke with Buddha judge and his
husband Chaston about the campaign in an
interview for CBS Sunday morning so
chasten when did the word president come
into the household in a serious way
I specifically remember a moment when we
were we were getting ready for bed and I
was folding some laundry and we were
just going over his day what had
happened at his political retreat and he
had mentioned I'm thinking maybe you
know about running for president
remember saying president like for real
or what you're really thinking about
that and uh and that was last last year
late summer I think we really started
cooking up the idea you can watch our
full interview with Mayor Pete Budaj on
Sunday morning here on CBS